what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we're going to be talking
about Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
including spoilers this is a spoiler
discussion and I'm gonna have my friend
Wendy over from the movie couple on here
in just a bit but first just want to say
that I did truly love this film a lot of
you have been saying that hey you said
you didn't like it because of this one
aspect of the movie no that doesn't mean
I didn't like it I actually thoroughly
enjoyed it but I will say these side
half cyborg people that are like fused
with animals infused with humans I do
hate and I really hated that aspect of
the movie however in turn it made me
hate the villain more High evolutionary
and I think this is one of the greatest
villains that we've ever seen in the MCU
because you absolutely hate him and it's
not like he's saying Hey I want to save
the universe so in order to do that I
gotta do some bad stuff that's not
really how it works he just is kind of
evil and it's really nice to see that
he's just kind of evil and that's his
motive he's an evil guy doing evil
things making everything the way he
wants it to be not for the greater good
but for selfish reasons for himself so
right away I gotta say that the the
Guardians of the Galaxy 3 villain the
high evolutionary it takes it for me
because I truly hated his guts and
that's what you want out of the villain
so the movie is definitely one of the
best from Marvel's but the villain is
top three to come from Marvel like
absolutely and I did love the movie and
the villain is a good part of that movie
but also just seeing all of the
characters on screen together for one
last time it just hits you really hard
it really does it hit you just so hard
and I loved it and I have Wendy here
with me today because like I said
um I did love the movie but I'm since I
have such an aversion to like the half
cyborg half living creatures thing that
it's like a personal bias to like not
liking a lot of the movie but everybody
asks them to love it Wendy included who
is sitting next to me the entire time
who I you know we were all crying like
we've heard like I I think I really
heard John crying I keep poking at him
for that even though we were all crazy I
think it was the people behind us was it
behind us okay
I heard very awesome John did sniffle
sorry John we all did we all did he's
not the only one but I did hear him like
a like a sniffle here and there but I
think it was whoever sat behind us were
like in their fields
yeah well and it's emotion it's a very
emotional movie like from the very
beginning okay and this is you know like
we mentioned in the beginning this is
spoilers guys so we're getting into
spoilers here spoiler review spoiler
talk you know Rockets like hurt and
dying from the very beginning and right
from then they just go into his story
arc of how he's experimented on right
and then he has all of his other friends
who are experimented on and it's like so
dark
but it's like you're invested in rocket
obviously over the years right so you
just it's just very it hits hard so yes
tears
let us know if you guys cried down below
we I I did a few sniffles uh here and
there shed some tears I think Wendy did
as well so Wendy what were your overall
thoughts about the movie because I know
you said you loved it at the end what
were your particular likes so I feel
like
um chapter to close out you know I I
will call it quote unquote James Gunn's
Guardians of the Galaxy right
um so it's a nice farewell to uh this
chapter and this Arc and especially for
specific characters who
um are either going to move on or and
we're focusing on you know new different
characters in a different team at the
end which I'm sure we'll touch on that
in a little bit and I think overall what
I really enjoyed is that they I feel
like this movie The Tone's a little bit
darker obviously because yeah somebody
in their team like their life is
basically hanging in Balance so that's
going to definitely tug on your
heartstrings especially in the third
movie
um but I think they balanced it well
that's what I liked about it between
like the really emotional stuff but not
losing the tone of like the chaoticness
that is the Guardians where they're all
screaming at each other and I know I
read somebody's like and I don't know
who it is it was somewhere on the
internet and they're like this movie is
so loud they're all just playing at each
other I'm like oh they've been yelling
since the first movie did you not watch
the first two yeah so let us know if
like you felt like there was less
yelling I guess in the previous two but
I feel like it's just as much
um yeah and I think the one thing that
really got me because I said in my like
reaction tweet was that I felt it gave
me the feeling of when I was watching an
an Avengers Assemble film like the
original Avengers or like end game slash
Infinity War so the
the consequences aren't as high as like
the snap and sandals right sure
um so it's kind of more like so think of
it in the ways that it's condensed down
to just like the Guardians of the Galaxy
bubble but in the hallway scene
and I just got that feeling of watching
a comic strip coming to life which is
how I felt in the very first Avengers
where I was like oh my God we're getting
this so it brought that feeling back of
the Ensemble film and things are at risk
and we're working together to get to the
next thing and who's that uncertainty of
you don't know who's gonna make it out
of this right yeah and I think and I
think that just I really just enjoyed
having that feeling back because I was
so invested in every moment
yeah and even uh that scene leads into
like the final scene with the high
evolutionary and they each like you know
it's really cool it's like a it's like a
big combo like if you're playing in a
fighting game you know what I mean it's
like you know Star-Lord hits them with
the guns and then Drax like clotheslines
and it's like each of them is like
hitting him and hitting him and hitting
him and it's like it's really cool to
see like you said like that Ensemble
it's just like they come together and
they all do like what they each
individually do
as a team to take him down right that in
that hallway scene and then on that
final scene uh but you said something
that I I want to actually get your input
on and I want the you know everybody to
leave comments about this as well no one
died in the Guardians that is like
obviously spoiler right yeah obviously
they killed Lila and they killed you
know florentes which is like super sad
like that was so sad it was so sad that
they died I wasn't expecting the Lola
broke me like I had a feeling where they
were gonna do it and I was like not like
this I know well I had seen some like we
see we see the trailers and I thought
some scenes from the trailers were going
to be where they reunite like after
years and years I was like oh no I saw
the scene in the movie it's like oh no
this scene happens while they're here I
was like she might die I was like oh
gosh and then they did and it was so sad
um so that part was like really really
sad and we talked to James Gunn after
and uh you know we we were talking to
him we were like you know nobody died
um and we and we thought like we thought
maybe the trailers were teasing Rocket's
death a little bit too much for him to
die I was like but maybe that was your
plan like Hey we're trying to make it
seem like we're pushing it too hard so
he won't die but in fact he will die and
he's like well the whole point was to
make you believe that he was gonna die
he's like but I killed Lyla in them none
of the Guardians died yeah so my
question to you is because I thought
they were gonna die I think a lot of you
know the fans out there thought at least
one girl I I thought Drax was dead for
sure for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah but
yeah we did you like the fact that no
one died or are you are you happy with
that or do you think it would have been
a better like ending if some of them did
die because you know people always talk
about there's no Stakes there's no
Stakes blah blah blah blah no one dies
so did you like that or did you not I
personally liked it I'm glad they all
kind of got sort of a happy end what did
you think I'm kind of I'm with you on
this I don't necessarily need to have
stakes in a character you know being
like killed off in a movie for me to
like enjoy it and say steaks are high
you can have high stakes without killing
off a character and I think this movie
handled it well because it's still a
farewell it's very clear who is not
going to be back for the next next
installment which like if you follow
industry news you already kind of have
an inkling of who may not return but it
leaves the window for them to do a cameo
here and there right later on so I think
the way they handled is good gives what
it gives the characters and the actors
the option to like come back to you know
build a story whatever whatever it may
be for the next thing where it may or
may not require a cameo right um and I
think
it's better that they didn't
kill off especially for Rocket like he
had such a great Arc and it ended at the
end of this where the realization of who
he is and what he's become kind of comes
full circle I want him to keep on living
with that new sort of mindset right and
you know same for Peter and Gamora and
literally all of them so I think this
was a great like final Discovery
self-discovery episode an episode but
chapter for them and then they can
continue on in whatever Canon or movie
that they will continue to exist in
I agree I
first of all I do like that it's still
open for some of them to have their own
story arcs uh especially rocket like he
is like you said it's just it's to see
where he started and where he is now in
like his different mindset and
everything like that I'm excited and I
got you know at the end where they're
like saying they're going their
different ways in Rockets like all sad
because he realizes like oh this is it
like the Guardians are done but they're
like nah it's you you have to lead the
Guardians I was like that's really cool
right because in the first movie he's
like I didn't ask to be made and he's
like he thinks I'm stupid and yeah you
know he's everyone's making fun of him
and he feels like he's just like this
freak he's like I didn't ask to be you
know turned into a monster and now it's
like no he's the leader of the Guardians
of the Galaxy they own nowhere their act
they were an actual like Universal team
right and then like that's his story arc
it's really cool
um and I want to talk about
the high evolutionary but first big
thank you to our sponsors Marvel's
Guardians of the Galaxy video game if
you're sad that the MCU Guardians of the
Galaxy Trilogy has ended here's
something that will satisfy your craving
for more Guardians now I know most
people have probably heard about this
game but Marvel's Guardians of the
Galaxy is a single player story-driven
action-adventure game out now for
PlayStation and Xbox consoles and PC
I've been hearing people Rave about this
game for a while it won best narrative
at the game awards in 2021 and now that
I've played it I definitely understand
why it is awesome this game is set in a
completely new and original Universe
these aren't the Guardians from the
comics or the movies but they're
inspired by both so they feel fresh and
familiar at the same time it's a fun and
epic story but it also has a lot of
heart with deep character arcs that
highlight the personalities of the
Guardians you get to spend 20 hours with
those Guardians so you get to see and
experience them in a way that you never
have before now the whole game is about
you playing as Star-Lord and trying to
lead the Guardians they all feel like
living breathing characters so you truly
get to experience something really
unique in being their leader calling the
shots and trying to bring those strong
personalities together it really makes
you feel for what Star Lord has to do
now of course you know that one of the
greatest things about the Guardians is
the music this game features a massive
soundtrack from an epic orchestral score
to classic 80s tracks and an original
Rock album created just for the game the
game includes many outfits for the
Guardians inspired by the comics and the
MCU including suits inspired by the 2008
Guardians of the Galaxy Comics just like
in Guardians volume 3. get your copy by
clicking the link in the description
down below
so the high evolutionary I've seen
people who had seen the movie early like
us raving about this villain because
he's so hateable
and he is like I think a lot for a lot
of people I can say everybody but for a
lot of people like a soft spot is like
animals right yeah pets and stuff you
know and essentially he's like taking
your pets and your animals and like
experimenting on them killing some of
them and uh it makes them very hateable
there and especially because you know he
has the whole count on Earth and he just
kills everybody blows it up you know
tells rocket you know what do you do
you're a piece of crap like you're not
coming to the perfected world like that
was never the plan like you think you're
gonna go there you know it's just so
he's I think he was pretty dang perfect
as far as a villain goes what did you
think about him I really liked him as a
villain I I think the ACT I can't
pronounce his name I'm so sorry to say
my life all right what Lauren said Well
Done sir from covering Peacemaker oh
that's right because he's yeah he is
fantastic so like I also
appreciate that they didn't always go
not saying he's an unknown actor because
he's certainly known and you know his
resume speaks for itself but he didn't
go for a quote-unquote like Marquee name
to play the villain which I super enjoy
because like I felt like I was watching
religious through thespian work on
screen and I felt like he helped Elevate
the movie I really liked him as as a
villain because he's so selfish and
egotistical and he's got this this
insane attitude about like creating
Perfection and you know what they kind
of say about him Rocket says about him
at the end uh it's just it's just
everything was Full Circle so I really
liked how they wrapped it up my only
thing was I felt like because this is
the first
and I guess last time
we're going to get to see Ohio
revolutionary that I want it a little
bit more with him and I know it's hard
to split time when you have a full-on
Ensemble movie and you have to
everybody's got to get their spotlights
yeah so it's it's a lot to ask for plus
they introduce Adam Warlock in this one
like finally right right so I I would
have liked to see a little bit more of
like flashbacks and I know we got plenty
but I don't feel like his character got
the full flesh out
yeah I think a lot of it really came
with rockets flashbacks yeah you know
yeah and I guess I didn't realize it
till now you're kind of right like in
real time there wasn't so much of him
right but and I wanted that I would like
like yeah no we spent a lot of time with
uh what's the planet were they not the
planet but when they infiltrated and it
was like the bio matter
oh yeah yeah yeah place that they that
they went to like we spent quite a lot
of time there and it was like really
cool looking action scenes but like if
we cut that back just a little bit and
gave a little bit more to use a little
bit more of that time to the higher
revolutionary I think that would have
been really great yeah now that you
mentioned it we did spend quite a bit of
time in that that place yeah
um which was really interesting and I
definitely I definitely thought Drax was
dying there like I for sure thought he
was gonna die because he got hit and
then he got hit again several times
since got like yeah yeah and it was very
clear that that weapon was very powerful
and I definitely thought he was dead
there but yeah we could have I could
have dealt with like a little bit a
little less there I did like it was very
colorful like when they were going there
with their astronaut suits and
everything like that and uh the funny
part where you know he's trying to talk
to Gamora and they're like everyone can
hear you that was like that was pretty
good classic Guardians right yeah what
do you mean blue isn't this yeah yeah
the blue is red and blue I know he's
like what did he say like
it seemed like intuitive or something
like that like yeah it's like you should
know that right it's it's like so funny
the way that they they think and operate
but as far as like the high evolutionary
goes like I would have liked to see more
like he was very rageful right like he
got pissed off a lot and in that scene
where they're like trying to take over
and he just like unleashes his power and
like destroys the entire like Bridge
like to see a lot of that would have
been really cool he was a great villain
but I think I agree with you I would
have liked to see a little bit more of
that from more layers more yeah more
scenes of that I do like how
I do like the connection with rocket to
where he's like I have Crea like I've
created this he created The Sovereign
which like I I said in like a bunch of
videos I'm like I bet you he created
them and I was so happy that that was
true on top of the movie too yeah he
created The Sovereign and like all these
other people and like
he's still he was the whole entire time
though he's like focused on Rocket
because he's like but these people can't
really think for themselves he's like
they're perfect except for the fact that
they they can't really do much on their
own but rocket is the one who figured
out like all these problems you know
with like one of his first batch of
things where they couldn't involve he
figured out how to fix that and it's
like it's always fixated on Rocket he's
always fixated like this stupid little
raccoon that I experimented on he became
like obsessed he did obsessed with it
yeah he needed his brain because it was
like he was even smarter than high
evolutionary which pissed him off yeah
and that's where that Obsession became
because one he's mad at him but two he
needs him so he can perfect the other
batches right of the new subject so it
was really cool to see that kind of like
it's a it's a weird connection but it is
a connection and like you said like an
obsession what yeah what did you think
about it Warlock
there's a lot of mixed feelings about
Adam Warlock yes there is and so before
going into this and I still haven't yet
but before going into this I really
didn't know very much about Adam Warlock
just like very surface level stuff and
even I would say even less so I went in
with almost like someone who who went
into it blind without knowing the source
material so the way he was portrayed
didn't really bother me too much I was a
little curious I was like oh I wonder if
he's like this in the film because they
played him as a very uh with a very
young mind right like very childlike
almost but this powerful guy you know
rageful I know we're not really rageful
but powerful
um so then it was revealed and they kind
of put that in that like he was taken
out of the Cocoon early and that's why
he is the way it is I was like oh okay
so then I after the film having
conversations with people with with
Justin
um and they're like yeah so Adam in the
comics is nothing like that I go oh I
see I can see how nothing yeah yeah so I
was like you understand that mixed
feelings
super strong
was he not super strong to you in the
film so well so Ray that's the thing is
like he is super sure but like in the
comics he's like super mature and he
gets and he's with Gamora in the comics
which is like I was like maybe they're
going with her with her or like yeah
I don't think that's happening in this
one uh maybe down the line because he
still created you know he was
genetically created so I'm sure he'll
grow faster than normal I mean he's
already a full human body right
um I I do like that they explained that
that and it goes back to that Obsession
he took him out of the Cocoon early and
Aisha was even like yo you did this he's
like this because you wanted to get the
raccoon right it's like you should have
let him sit a little bit more and he
would have been just complete his mind
completely formed and everything and he
would have been able to do whatever he
freaking wants to do because he's
already super super powerful but he is
like that mind of like a young boy
um I didn't mind because I like how they
presented that and they kept him and now
he's gonna be a guardian or you know
whatever uh comes with that I do think
he's gonna be in the MCU you know
originally Adam Warlock belongs he was
already a part of in the comics right a
part of the Guardians that's what I've
heard but I'm confronting with you
um yeah I mean yeah he's definitely on
the Guardians team and they have a lot
of history together
um what's interesting is you know that
the the mark on his head is supposed to
be for the Soul Stone or the soul gem as
they refer to in the comics yeah they
didn't touch on that at all and I felt
like it was at all obvious I was like
yeah hello are we gonna mention maybe I
guess maybe for the follow-up films
well that you know and that's the things
they always change things like uh like
in in the infinity war comics Adam
Warlock you know goes into the Soul
Stone the soul realm and he brings
everybody out and they go and fight
Thanos it's like you know obviously
there was no like Soul World Soul realm
wow Infinity war end game but like
that's a big part of his Arc in that
film like he's one or in the in the
comics he's a major part of that and
that's one major thing that he does and
um he you know that wasn't anywhere in
the films and that wasn't addressed like
you said in this and I was like well why
does he have a thing in his head then
like was something plugged into him
there or something like are you gonna
put us
at all right it wasn't so that was like
my one little problem I was like why I
was like I get it like he took he got
taken out of cocoon early and he's kind
of a boy he's not fully formed yet I
could deal with that especially since
they're keeping him around and I'll see
more of him later I'll see more of them
mature Adam Warlock later I'm fine with
that but what why why does he still have
the thing in his head I want to know if
there are more stones or something out
there like what was that about you know
yeah
we'll get the answer right exactly so I
didn't it's not that I really just I
didn't dislike him at all I thought it
was really good I thought Will Poulter
did an excellent job he definitely
buffed up a lot for it and I'm sure they
put a little bit in the suit as well but
was there anything that you disliked
about the movie
zootopia people just the cyborg people
like half robot half animal half robot
half human I hated that right that's
like my I felt you squirmy next to me
when we were in like a fat family's home
you were just like squirming your seed
but I didn't know why until afterwards I
hated it but anyways what did you just
like about the minute so it's like a
weird thing to dislike but it was the
[Music]
yeah of course I felt like like the the
11d million endings that we were getting
in Lord of the Rings I felt like we were
getting like 28 endings oh yeah at the
end of the game I was like oh this is
the end this is the end and it felt it
just fell right right right right like
we were yeah but the pacing it just
threw it off because I felt like it the
pacing was really really good you know
like first accident even the third act
and we got to the end I was like okay
all right we done here okay we're done
so yeah it's just it felt it felt a
little weird a little off for me at the
end but like honestly I I feel like I
need to watch it because I've only seen
it once I would like to watch it again
to kind of
sit back and relax about it and watch it
and and take it in
uh in a more relaxed manner just because
the first time you're seeing it as like
journalist or critic or review or
whatever you're you're kind of I don't
want to say rigid that's a really bad
explanation but you're
a little bit more tense about everything
sure you're not able to like be like the
audience and and really really like let
the emotions overcome you like I held
the tears just so I can like make sure
right right right I was like don't cry
don't do it
yeah I I agree with that and I think
that I think it just comes like you said
with like the big Ensemble because like
if you're wrapping up the story of the
Guardians well there's you know four or
five six members you know you keep
adding more like craglin and Cosmo and
stuff like that like there's there
actually is a lot to wrap up so but I
know what you're saying it's like the
Lord of the Rings it's like the scene
where uh they all come into the bed and
you're like oh this is like kind of the
end and then it goes on it's like oh no
they're going back to the Shire and it's
like oh no wait now Frodo is leaving
with Bilbo oh it's just I I I get that
yeah yeah but it's just like something
so little to nitpick on you know right
and they had to do it because it's like
yep the show what Star Lord's gonna do
and you have to show you know like
nebula is gonna do and then then we have
the post-credit scenes you know which
those are post credit scene so that is
what it is but it did show that Adam's
staying rocket stain Groot and
everything so I'm excited for that and
overall
did you rank this movie like do you have
a ranking I think I I gave it like an
eight out of 10 because I hate that
cyborg crap again that's very personal
but it influences how I feel about the
movie yeah and I thought we could have
had
it was a little long to me uh I thought
we could have had better like more at
more action and that could have come
with like the high evolutionary uh like
that like the action scenes that we did
get were awesome and even the dialogue
that we got in between like the
monologue where they're going and and
Peter and they're like oh we're heading
directions like we're gonna kill
everyone and Peter's like no we're not
he's like some people just one guy one
pathetic guy like that's awesome like I
love all of that stuff but I couldn't I
could have had just a tiny bit more
action like there was enough in there
talking about like dang that sucks there
wasn't a lot so I kind of give like an
eight out of ten I think I know eight
out of ten is is fair uh it's definitely
has some flaws but I think as a closing
chapter for you know what James Gunn
wanted to do with with the the Guardians
I really I really liked it a lot was
really entertaining it's it's probably
one of my favorite Marvel movies
in a while yeah oh for sure for sure
yeah including shanxi I love Shan chi I
love Sean Chi too yeah because people
people ask me they're like better than
Shanty I was like I don't know
and it's one that gets his like first
movie and this is the third Guardians
like I don't really think it's like the
same no it hits you different because
it's like wow this is the end of like
this team we've seen them right movies
and infinity war and get all it's like
wow this is the end so it hits you
differently so it's hard to compare it
really is yeah but I did like you said I
had I had more of an Infinity war in
game field than I did like a solo movie
feel
agree
um where would you rank this out of the
three Guardians films all right the
third because
that's cyborg stuff like you know what I
mean like yeah I just because because
that will prevent me from watching this
over and over and over again it will
well you'll watch it you just have to
skip those parts probably like it's like
the whole movie like it's like there's
like a big movie it's a big part of the
movie what would you wait if it doesn't
does nebula no that does not bug me at
all it's when I can like see your
insides right and it's like I can see
where it like connects to your flesh and
so like that pig that was terrible that
was terrible I hated it oh okay okay
okay well where would you rate I'm just
trying to make a mental note like what
to never show you just in case thank you
yeah he would not be interested in this
I would go um
one's your favorite
three second and second is third
okay that sounds like the blue and
yellow button s yeah the the the yeah
right the first one's a classic and I
can say oh that's everyone yeah favorite
but a lot of people said this was their
favorite Guardians film so far so let us
know what you guys thought about it down
below in the comments is this your
favorite where do you rank the three
Guardians films that's what we want to
do